let's talk about how to detoxify thousands of
toxic chemicals out of your body but do in a
way that's very safe there are many chemicals
in our environment bisphenol a pcbs heavy metals
certain toxic plastics and bile solids have you
ever heard of that before bile solids sound pretty
benign right but what you may not realize is
bio solids are treated sewage sludge it's a very
interesting book that i'm reading called toxic
sludge is good for you this book is more about
how certain groups use pr public relations to
make something that is normally harmful to the
environment and make it actually good for you so
in this book they describe how they came up with
this new term biosolids and actually redefined
treated sewage sludge as a nutrient-rich organic
byproduct i'm not kidding i mean bile salads
contain over sixty thousand toxic substances this
is the stuff that exits your toilet and it goes
right into a sewage treatment plant where they're
processing this material and actually selling it
as an ingredient in your pet food in animal feeds
and fertilizer there's at least eighty thousand
probably hundreds of thousands of different
poisons or toxins call it xenobiotics
that we're exposed to on a daily basis
now our bodies have a defense mechanism for this
it is a series of detoxification pathways that
will turn these poisons into harmless particles
which is then eliminated through our waste
and urine it's called bile transformation where
you have these very powerful enzymes they're
called cytochrome p450 enzymes that are meant to
break down all these poisons and keep us healthy
so what i want to talk about is what you should be
doing or eating to keep these toxins from causing
disease here's a really interesting book this is
the international agency of research on cancer by
the world health organization and it's all about
cruciferous vegetables and a really big effect
is the ability of cruciferous vegetables to
induce bile transformation so this is one thing
you should be consuming on a regular basis kale
broccoli brussels sprouts cabbage arugula bok choy
now bile salts your body makes bile you can
also take bile this is very very important
anytime you do a detox you should always
start by taking bile salts for a few days
and then do your detox because taking
purified bile salts helps to start
the flow through the liver because when you
start to detoxify and you start killing off
certain pathogens they release endotoxins that
then shut down the bile ducts and that's why
you might feel toxic from detoxifying so
bile salts help you eliminate xenobiotics
naturally a lot of the chemicals from your
liver should be coming out with the help of bile
also the microbes in your gut help you detoxify
and they also have the ability to make this enzyme
to help you break down these poisons and one
of the things i really recommend is to combine
this with this so if you were to take a pre-biotic
which is like a fiber let's say cabbage and we
ferment it into sauerkraut cabbage is not just
cruciferous but it's a prebiotic and a probiotic
so sauerkraut is a great food to help you detoxify
and the cool thing about doing this with food is
it happens slowly so you don't really feel it
now there's many other different vegetables and
herbs that will help you detoxify garlic is a big
one rosemary thyme and clove all have this enzyme
another thing to realize is a lot of these
chemicals create a lot of free radical
damage in the body and the foods that you eat have
antioxidants but your body also makes antioxidants
it's called endogenous antioxidants especially
when you fast when you're doing fasting you're
putting your body in the state of autophagy
which not only accelerates repairing the
damage in the body but also the clearing out
of pathogens but fasting will help increase
your endogenous antioxidant networks so you'll
have a lot more antioxidants not to mention
your immune system is stronger and the body will
resist the stress from the free radical damage
if you're doing organic foods okay certified
organic foods it's not going to have these in them
the chain whole foods also recently made an
agreement that they're not going to include any
of their products with bile salads i would also
make sure when you buy pet food that you read the
ingredients and make sure it does not have these
byproducts because if you're going to look at
these nutrient-rich organic byproducts it sounds
like it's really really healthy but it's not
anyway thanks for watching and i'll see you in the
next video before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you want
to know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able
to answer everyone's call but i put the number
down below so you can call and get some help